hi this is dr. Gregory Sadler I'm a
professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason I o
where we put philosophy into practice
I've studied and taught philosophy for
over 20 years and I find that many
people run into difficulties reading
classic philosophical texts sometimes
it's the way things are said or how the
text is structured but the concepts
themselves are not always that
complicated and that's where I come in
to help students and lifelong learners
I've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to YouTube many
viewers say they find them useful what
you're currently watching is part of a
new series of shorter videos each of
them focused on one core concept from an
important philosophical text I hope you
find it useful as well in chapter 10 of
his manalo gym and some is going to make
a very interesting distinction and that
distinction ties in with what you could
call his master argument or set of
arguments running throughout the
mauville gym specifically it's there to
try to explain what just got discussed
in Chapter nine which runs throughout
other parts of the work namely that
created things before they're created
exist in a certain way in the Divine
Word there's a video specifically about
that so I don't need to rehearse that
here and the the question that he's
trying to grapple with is well how how
do they exist in the Divine Word you
know are they or the divine reason
there's some sort of expression or
utterance within that but how do they
how does that work it when we say they
have utterance or expression here that's
a translation of the latin term little
cutesy oh come on something speaking we
get elocution from that as well and so
Ansel is going to distinguish between
three types of audiences or expressions
or we might say three moles and the
argument is going to be ultimately that
only one of these types is the type that
corresponds to how the Divine Word
thinks up or or speaks or however you
want to put it the things that are not
yet in existence into existence through
creation but this has a lot of
interesting ramifications for us human
beings even if we put aside all this
discussion of the divine work and what
he's saying here as a side note also
ties in importantly with the ontological
argument and which we'll discuss in
another another some videos on the pro
slow diem Ana ties in with an Psalms
very important work on truth and the
conception of different kinds of truth
so put all that or back pocket let's
look at what this distinction actually
is so handsome is going to say we know
from frequent experience that we can say
one of the same thing in three ways and
there's three ways that are being
distinguished here you notice that the
third way actually can be distinguished
into two different kinds of way so we
might say there's there's four ways but
at least there's a distinction between
different kinds of sayings or expressing
things he says we can say anything by
making perceptible use of perceptible
signs what does that mean signs that can
be perceived by the bodily senses so
what would those be well I'm making
signs like that right now I'm talking to
you you're hearing what I'm saying
that's hearing I've rid the things above
the chalkboard those are words and
letters those are science right and the
signs are as we know not the thing but
they in some ways signifi so they are
signs and our use of them it is
perceptible you can hear me talking and
if you were talking to me what you're
not because you're on the other end of
the camera I would hear you when you
write your youtube comments about this i
will look at the letters and the words
that you you have and those will be
perceptible signs okay so that's one
very important way now he says that we
also can think in our minds those signs
to ourselves so you know think about the
word perceptible now I kind of imagined
that in your head look away from the
screen and just think perceptible spell
it for yourself right when you have to
spell something you're not doing it out
loud but just in wordly is he saying
here thinking imperceptibly within
ourselves the very same signs that are
perceptible when they are outside
ourselves there is one way in which we
do in fact exercise our minds thank
goodness everybody isn't always saying
as you think that's on there by
everything that they're thinking as a
matter of fact some things people are
surprised when they were thinking
something to themselves and it pops out
of their mouth because there's a
distinction between perceptible you
societies and imperceptibly thinking
those perceptible signs within your head
right dr. Sandler should get a new
jacket because he's had that too long
you can think that right and then
there's there's actually writing that
down but do you think very often by use
of linguistic science and Anselm's not
knocking that but it doesn't think that
that's all that are you thinking
comprises as a matter of fact getting
closer to the reality of the thing he
says there's also expressing the things
themselves what it is that we're trying
to express inwardly in one's mind he
says not by using these signs about
whether perceptibly or imperceptibly but
thinking them inwardly by you so one
thing or another a corporeal image as
when we imagine something you know we
take something in I suppose when we
recall in memory the taste of
steak or a turnip or a bar a chocolate
or India Pale Ale I pick whatever you
like I probably prefer the India Pale
Ale myself very robust it tastes right
that's a corporeal image that's
something different and he's going to
give us some examples in just a moment
we can also understand the thing itself
in a different way that gets more
according to handsome to the heart of
the matter by thinking it through it
what he calls an understanding of reason
he doesn't explain exactly what an
understanding of reason is but that's
that's a literal translation of rock
Tiona skin selective on which he's using
here and some does not make a
distinction by the way in his works the
way some medieval philosophers do
between intellectus and rossi oh they
are within a continuum they both named
the same thing so he says for example in
one way I say a man i express a man when
I signify him by the word man pretty
straightforward right right the word on
board say it out loud you hear it I
signify him in another way when I think
that same word siren Lee like what I'm
thinking about Gregory samer or until
the hunt or anselm of canterbury or mr.
X on the other side of the camera then
says in another way when my mind sees
the man himself the human being him or
herself either through an image of a
body or in some something visual perhaps
or perhaps even tactile some people have
quite pungent auras that they bring
around with them you know there's a lot
of different senses that this court
could correspond to thinking some of
these voice as well or through reason
he's
us as what it thinks it is universal
essence which is rational moral animal
each of those is a way of expressing the
same one thing in this case but they
pick out different aspects and some of
them are closer to the thing itself or
they bring the thing into the mind you
might say more than others do the meter
word man is just a work you could also
use it on bread and in Mandarin or you
know in French or whatever else we want
to use you know I throw pulse in classic
recon it is a modern Greek homo and
Latin and then we can think to ourselves
of you know what it is to be a human
being that gets more towards a court
anselm actually goes so far as to
endorse a view of language and
expression that not too many people do
these days he says each of these three
kinds of utterance corresponds to its
own kind of word the words of the kind
of utterance I put third and last this
year when they're not about things that
are not unknown are natural they're the
same among all people so he's saying
that when we when we have a concept the
concept itself is not something that is
just you know connected with copy of
linguistic signs we're actually getting
at the core of what something is so to
grasp human being as rational mortal
animal which is an achievement is
possible whether you're speaking
Mandarin or Arabic or English or Latin
or pick whatever else to you look if we
met you know people on Mars and they
spoke some you know language that was
conveyed with I don't know expressive
dance that was the only thing they get
still nonetheless had of this natural
language in common with us but notice
that it's somewhat distanced from the
linguistic science so there there's some
work that has to be done there and he
also even to acts
you know things that use their own names
in order to signify themselves like the
vowel a they're the linguistic sign you
know it corresponds to the thing itself
right now to go back to the issue of the
word he says no utterance of anything
whatsoever comes as close to the thing
as that which consists of words this
work furthermore no other worded
anyone's reason can be it similar to the
thing whether it is yet to exist or
already exist as that s how the thing
exists in the word which brings us back
full circle and again I suggest if that
doesn't make sense to you should watch
the video on the pre-existence of the
existence of things in in the word but
here were primarily interested in this
distinction between what we could say is
the realm of the linguistic or semiotic
and the realm of as an some conceives of
it you know grasping things more truly
as they are